Very good afternoon.
I hope everybody is informed about the
class.
One of you, can you let me know?
Do you have a group?
Am I audible?
Let me just enable your mics.
I hope you can hear me.
Yes, ma'am. Yes, ma'am,
we can hear you and it's already
That's fine, we can hear you.
scheduled in the calendar.
Okay, no,
I think by mistake there was some
cancellation.
I hope you did not get any cancellation
e-mail.
Did you guys get any cancellation e-mail,
huh?
I really got, actually.
We got cancellation e-mail yesterday,
madam,
Oh, got it.
but just now we have been informed that
there is another madam Raja Vadhana.
Okay.
Sec.
Her session is cancelled, yours is on.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. By mistake,
they did something about my session.
So I hope everybody,
because of this confusion,
I hope everybody will get that message.
Do you have a group or something on which
you can post that there is a class?
Somebody just posted, ma'am.
Yes, ma'am, just posted, yeah.
Okay, thank you. Thank you so much. Okay,
we will start.
So how was your NLP Applications paper?
Was it good?
It was easy, right? Was it difficult,
easy? How was it?
Please let me know. No comments.
Was it easy or not easy?
Was there any concern in the paper?
Everything what we learned in the contact
sessions came, right? Nothing out of it.
Even the review session I had taken.
I hope, yes, good, good. I'm happy.
Very good, very good, very good.
Yeah, it was good, man. Easy.
Madam,
they were there was numerical related to
that aspect, what is that called? Aspect.
Ha ha ha.
Something,
so there I committed mistake now to
Okay. Okay, that's fine. That's fine.
That's fine. Okay.
formula got mixed.
There was one more formula, no M.I.P.M.P.
I. or M.I. There were two formulae,
the two got mixed.
Ha.
Correct, correct. Okay, okay, okay.
No problem, it's fine.
Small mistakes is fine. But yeah,
so it was application oriented, so.
Sentiment analysis, no,
that was sentiment analysis aspect level.
Correct, correct, correct, correct. Yes.
Okay. So otherwise it was good, right?
I hope assignment one,
everybody has finished.
So for the NLP Applications,
I just wanted to remind you,
I will also remind Professor Raja Vadhana
and I don't know what's happening.
Yeah,
so here if you go to the announcement,
just give me a second. I had opened it,
yeah.
This is for the, by the way,
I have also uploaded the solution for the
regular,
I have requested to upload the makeup
paper solution also,
that also will be updated on the Canvas
portal.
So please be mindful about these
deadlines. So there is this,
quiz 2 coming up and there is importantly
there is this webinar 3 coming up.
So sorry, yeah,
webinar 3 is coming up on 7th of July,
which is the day of three days later.
So please attend that for sure.
And also there is this quiz 2 coming up.
on 22nd of July based on some of the
pre-mid sem content and some of the
post-mid sem. Of course,
best two out of three will be selected
for your final exam.
And also there is going to be a part of
situated learning.
Apart from this assignment one and two,
one is anyway over.
So the second assignment is going to be
uploaded soon based on the post mid sem
topic particularly,
but also maybe one or two topics from pre
mid sem might be included in your
programming assignment.
And there will be a situated learning
form that I will be sharing with all of
you.
So I will let you know what you are
supposed to do.
It is going to be the same deadline for
that, 30th July to 16th of August.
In that,
it's just a form wherein you have to
enter how this course is helped you in
your industry application,
how it is relevant for your different
projects and so on.
So we want those kinds of income.
inputs so there is a 5 percentage
weightage for that so that I will let you
know maybe next weekend. Okay.
Let me just continue.
So let me present this content.
So I am also trying to arrange one expert
session, or rather if possible,
to let's see,
depending on the time availability by
industry expert.
So I have a couple of friends in AI for
Bharatesh.
which is a SARVAT initiative and a lot of
IIT Madras faculty members are,
so if you go to the AI for Bharatesh
website, they are working for,
even SARVAT is working for that.
So there are a lot of research
opportunities also if you are interested.
And last time I had tried,
luckily there was time for that.
Let's see if possible this time also,
I will try to arrange that.
That is particularly for Indian machine
translation. Apart from that,
there is one more expert session that I'm
trying to arrange by Google expert.
There is 1 colleague of mine who is
working with, actually he's the...
one of the bioneers of TensorFlow
libraries. So I'm trying to help,
I'm trying to get him for some expert
sessions. So if possible,
we will try to arrange that during either
webinar or contact sessions related to
the.
content. Okay, so let's see.
Let's hope for the best.
Let's see that the hope that the time
they are able to give the time according
to our sessions and webinar sessions.
That is a major challenge because
coordinating everybody's time is a big
challenge.
So now coming to today's contact session
content.
So we are going to start with an
interesting application.
which is machine translation. Now,
although many of you may not be having
this application in your respective
industry, I must say that this is a very,
very important application.
And this was suggested by all the
industry experts right from Google to
Microsoft.
to even academic experts from IITs as
well as abroad universities.
So this is a very,
very important topic and a very
interesting and important application of
NLP. So today's session,
Okay.
I am going to particularly talk about
what is the machine translation problem.
What are the applications?
What are the challenges? Of course,
we do have a lot of good systems which
exist, including Google Translate,
which gives pretty good accuracy for many
of the languages.
There are still a lot of challenges in
Indian machine translation.
As well as there are, so actually,
luckily, my supervisor,
Professor Ganesh Ramakrishnan,
he is involved in Bharatesh Jain,
which was a part of this AI. So,
it's a government funded kind of this by
IITB, and he's the...
founder of this particular initiative,
where they are trying to build the models,
LLM models,
instead of using training it on English,
they are trying to do it on Indian
languages.
So there is a lot of things that are
happening in Indian languages as well.
So there's a lot of scope for research
and
this as well. Okay,
so that's why I just wanted to give you
the importance of machine translation.
So we will talk about the applications,
what are the applications,
what are the challenges,
and we will cover all the possible
approaches that are used in automatic
machine translation.
We'll talk about an important problem,
significant problem in machine
translation, which is word alignment.
In fact,
the attention is all you need paper.
I am sure most of you might have read
that paper.
Talks about machine translation problem
and attention mechanism was primarily
to focus on this word alignment problem.
Okay,
so they had also taken the machine
translation as one of the use cases for
explaining the attention mechanism,
what tokens the algorithm should attend
to, et cetera, for translation problem.
So word alignment is in line with that.
We'll discuss what is word alignment and
why is it so much challenging.
To get this word alignment, of course,
today's session will touch upon the
statistical machine translation with some
mathematical bit of a mathematical
formulation,
but in and will also touch upon the
evaluation measures,
particularly the blue score,
which is a very popularly used evaluation
measure.
in machine translation.
We'll discuss that with an example
problem. So you can expect a problem also,
where you're in sem on that.
So we'll discuss that in detail.
So all this is going to be discussed now.
So first of all,
I just wanted to take a very quick input.
Is anybody working in machine translation
or?
or planning to do or anything related to
machine translation, please let me know.
Yeah.
Is anybody working in this area? No one?
Do you know this problem of machine
translation? What is this application?
Yes, can you hear me?
Nobody's working in this area. Okay,
Yes, ma'am.
no problem. So...
At least one thing that I know is,
say for example,
Yeah.
some of the languages are written from
left to right and English from left,
right to left.
Get it, get it.
Dadheech.
No, it's not just left to right.
There's also grammatical structure, right?
Yeah, yes, will be correct.
SVO and SOV. So English is SVO, right?
Subject, verb, object.
Whereas all our Indian languages are SOV.
So we use the verb at the end of the
What's it?
Subject, subject, object, object.
sentence, right? All the Indian languages.
So that's a major.
Correct.
change.
So that needs to be handled correctly.
Plus, Indian languages, I feel are,
I'm proud also that we are,
all the languages are phonetic.
We write exactly the way we speak, right?
Whereas English is a funny language,
BUT but, BUT put.
So the pronunciation is different,
phonetics is different,
writing is different.
So there are more challenges.
Whereas in Indian languages,
it's more beautiful and more accurate,
I must say. And I mean,
I don't want to compare it,
but it's phonetic language.
It's the way we speak is the same way we
write, right? So therefore,
I, so Indian languages has a lot of scope.
And in fact,
I'm proud to say that my mother had done
PhD from IIT Bombay long back, of course,
in the Pilani and grammar,
in Sanskrit grammar and for English
languages.
So University of Pennsylvania in US was
doing a lot of research that time,
including she has written to Chomsky and
many people had shown interest.
Unfortunately, she died very early,
so but there was a lot of work done by
her too in machine translation,
particularly in Pilani and grammar and so
on. So there is a lot of, of course,
IIT Bombay has always been very active.
in this area. They have a completely,
there is a CFILT,
there's a complete research building or
research centre for Indian languages.
So there's a lot of things that are
happening there,
even IIT Madras and a lot of other places.
There is a lot of interesting work which
is going on in this particular area.
So coming back to our slides,
so machine translation is basically,
it is use of the machines to
automatically translate the particular
language from one natural language to
another, either text or speech.
without any human intervention at during
the inference time.
So this is not as easy as it seems,
particularly for the low resource human,
low resource Indian languages.
We are going to have one particular
contact session focused completely on
Indian languages. Today,
I'm going to talk in general about the
machine translation, the challenges.
Applications evaluation,
which is of course applicable for all the
approaches as well as for Indian machine
translation.
So the idea is when you're doing
automatic machine translation,
you want to preserve the meaning,
of course. So suppose, for example,
Prime Minister,
President is travelling many a times
abroad for international relations, right?
Particularly in today's.
time we know that I am a peace supporter.
So we know that there is so much
happening in the world and if some kind
of a miscommunication can lead to a lot
of problems.
Even you can see now also the
communication gap, like the session,
right?
My session was by mistake cancelled,
right? So.
There can be,
and particularly when you're within one
language itself, there can be a ambiguity,
cancel below session and NLP application.
So there was actually reference to
another mail which was missed.
So this is a kind of a communication
issue which may happen, which may,
because of which there might be a lot of
blunders.
And particularly when you're doing
machine translation at an international
level for international tie-ups and so on,
you cannot afford to have a wrong
translation, wrong tone of speaking,
wrong fluency, everything will be very,
very critical, right? Plus,
when you're doing machine translation,
there are different challenges for.
text machine translation,
there are different challenges for speech
machine translation because the
pronunciation, the intonation,
a lot of our clues needs to be handled
when you're doing speech translation.
So also it has to be faithful,
it has to be fluent.
So there are a lot of,
and if you look at the languages that we
have across the world, so there are more
more than 7000 languages.
We of course know of very prominent ones,
but there are so many languages and so
much of, so when I say language,
it is knowledge, right?
So we may have a lot of long,
interesting and important knowledge base,
which is in some of the languages which
are dying because they are not spoken
frequently, right? So.
We don't want that knowledge to be lost
just because we are not able to
understand that knowledge.
So machine translation plays an important
role in all of these aspects. And today,
of course,
many of the languages are supported.
Of course,
India has 22 constitutional languages.
among them, most of them,
they are able to do it via different
mechanism.
Yet there are a lot of languages which
are, I mean,
like what they call Boli languages,
like they are just a spoken languages.
They may not have a proper script or they
may not have a proper material yet.
There could be a lot of knowledge base
which is embedded in those which needs to
be captured.
So there is a lot of knowledge which
needs to be captured and therefore
machine translation is a very important
problem.
And particularly in the neural network
area, this is gaining a lot of, I mean,
its momentum is picked up more in this
era because of these technology
advancements.
Applications I has already told you first
most important is global communication,
real time, social media, travel area,
e-commerce also it is very important.
Many of the organizations,
whether it's German, French, Japanese,
they do insist on their own local
languages.
So they want the softwares to be there,
which is working in their own,
the interfaces,
which needs to be developed for their own
customers or their own people of their
own country in their local languages.
So there are a lot of applications there
as well. In government, of course, sector,
there's a lot of scope, legal domain.
So we know most of the courts in India
run in local languages. So I was also,
unfortunately, PB,
Pushpak Bhattacharya passed away a few
years back.
He was doing a lot of interesting
projects in legal area, legal domain.
So there also,
this particular machine translation plays
an important role.
Localization,
we know that it's not that everybody
speaks English in India, right? Hardly,
I think 30 to 40% people must be speaking
English.
Most of them speak local languages.
Even I don't speak English at home.
So most of us use a lot of local
languages everywhere.
And localization industry is, again,
a very important application for machine
translation.
right?
Particularly if you're buying vegetables
or even your other things which are
Indian specific clothes or whatever,
you may not want to use any,
I don't even know whether there are
English words for it, right?
So it's a very interesting and important.
Again, in scientific and legal also.
Legal, I already told you, right?
There are a lot of
documents or knowledge or information
which is in local languages.
Accessibility is very, very important.
So language is going to help this barrier
of language causes a lot of people to
miss out on a lot of information and
knowledge.
So accessibility can be better if there
is a automatic machine translation
project, right? So of course,
we all know that Google Translate is one
of the most popularly used translation
application across the world.
It does have a lot of active users which
are using this. Earlier, if you,
I had actually worked in my PhD time,
I had worked, it was a decade or more,
rather, 2016, that already.
or even before that, 29 or 2011, sorry.
So very, very long ago, 15 years back.
So that time we had used this Giza plus
neural,
basically statistical machine translation
and all of these tools,
which Google was using at that point of
time. But today, of course,
they do use neural networks and a lot of
other.
So SMT is statistical,
but the ideas of alignment and
statistical are still used in the neural
models. OK, so today, of course,
we do have multimodal models also,
which are so it's a combination of
multilingual and multimodal,
so multiple languages and multiple
modalities, so that is also.
research area that is picking up.
So DeepL is another such platform where
we do use it automatically generating the
natural sounding translations and it is
preferred by a lot of professional
translators.
So this is also one of the commonly used.
platforms for machine translation.
Apart from that, Meta,
No Language Left Behind is also trying to
deal with a lot of translate.
So currently it is supporting 200,
but we saw there are 7000 plus.
So there is a lot of scope still there in
many other languages.
right? So there are a lot of,
now of course,
machine translation is not a very easy
problem. There is,
we already know that language itself has
so much of A ambiguity in terms of part
of speech.
We have seen a lot of ambiguity
challenges in our NLP course as well as
in the other courses.
So ambiguity is a big problem and this,
if you look at it,
Now we are dealing with two languages,
or rather,
we don't even know whether it's two or
multiple languages, right?
So the ambiguities become like 2, 4, 3, 4,
4, fold, and so on.
So that's a big challenge. Secondly,
there are idioms,
there are cultural aspects to every
language that also needs to be captured,
especially if you're...
doing in terms of the speech,
the intonation, the way you speak,
the tone in which you speak,
a lot of things matter.
So all this needs to be effectively
captured. Morphological, so again,
I'm coming back. So Turkish and Finnish,
apart from that, also,
I'm proud to say that Indian languages
are morphologically rich languages.
So this is what actually
My mother also had stated in her thesis
that we have these cases like Usnek, yeah.
So from which we can immediately come to
know the gender of a person, right?
Which is like a morphological,
we have these richness, right?
Because of which the ambiguity reduces to
a substantial extent.
which is not present in many languages,
maybe including English.
So this morphological richness may be
lost because English doesn't have it and
Indian languages have it.
So this needs to be, again,
this is one of the things that needs to
be captured.
Domain mismatch is again a problem.
Legal domain have.
their own set of vocabularies,
which may not have appropriate
translation in multiple languages.
So we need to figure out that medical
domain again in the, I mean,
domain specific kind of scenario,
finance domain.
It may be very difficult to translate.
I don't even know stocks and shares and
how will you translate these in the other
languages.
How will you explain it to the audience
in other languages? So it's a challenge,
right? Low resource, I already told you.
So many of the,
so most of the today's neural network
approaches do use a parallel corpora.
We'll talk about that shortly.
But most of these Indian or even
non-Indian, some of the languages.
They do not have enough resources to
train the model, right?
Even for fine tuning,
you may not have that much of a resource.
So how do you use it for these languages?
That's a challenge.
Data is a big challenge. And of course,
there are named entities.
There are other challenges,
which we will again talk.
Okay,
so resolution of this ambiguity is
definitely a must in the machine
translation.
So there could be syntactic ambiguities
like the SVO and SOV that I talked about
because of the way that the sentences are
framed like I eat a mango if I say me
khati amba or...
I don't know, I mean,
this is a too simple example,
but some of the complicated example where
you cannot infer what other person is
saying if it is grammatically incorrect,
right? Particularly small kids,
sometimes you don't even understand what
they're talking because it's all
gibberish.
They just mix and match words without
following any grammar rules.
Right,
so it becomes very difficult to
understand. That's a syntactic problem.
Semantic would be there are no equivalent
words like guitar. I don't even know.
Sitar is of course a string instrument,
but it's not same as guitar, right?
It's completely a different string
instrument.
So I don't even know whether there are
equivalent translation for sitar and
guitar.
in other languages. Other than that,
you could also have like a funny kind of
a thing, right? Out of sight, out of mind,
right? Because of these phrases.
Or then also another problem is sarcasm.
So one of my colleagues from IIT, Aditya,
I just came to know he received some
award also for this paper or something.
So he's done a lot, his PhD in sarcasm.
So he's, I think, doing, looking at,
he's in Australia.
So he's looking at some Australian
sarcasm versus Indian sarcasm,
some analysis on that.
So that's another interesting area,
sarcasm translation and finding out
sarcasm is again,
like in sentiment analysis,
translating that.
is a big challenge.
EDM translation is also a big challenge.
Then of course,
we know these are the simple challenges
that we have already seen because of the
context, the same word, right?
The like sem,
because of the polysemy and all of these
challenges,
same word has multiple meanings.
syntax we already talked about because of
the structure of the language,
SVO in English and SOV in Indian
languages. Arabic have VSO,
which is verb coming in the first.
So there are a lot of varieties that we
have across languages.
Then there is also something called as
pronoun drop.
right? So, tumne nadiya ko khana diya,
yes, I gave.
There are some implicit dropping of the
Pana pronouns. So,
how do you translate it correctly? Again,
so as I said, I gave her, if I say her,
at least I can make out, but if I say I,
I cannot make out whether it is male or
female.
right? So that's a challenge.
How do you translate it?
Then there is also a pronomial anaphora.
So when I say I,
so this is also called as anaphora
resolution.
So I saw the movie and it is good.
Is it referring to movie or is it
referring to I?
Obviously, from, we know,
because as a human being,
we know movie and it, right, gender,
because of that we can associate,
but for a machine, it is a challenge.
Semantic,
I already told you there might be
temporal semantic ambiguity,
like one is because of this sentence or
one is temporal after this sentence and
so on.
So there might be a lot of these
challenges.
Another challenge is lack of multiple
words. So for example,
In French,
you have a separate word for river that
flows into ocean and river that does not
flow into ocean. Whereas in English,
you may not have such different words.
So how do you translate it, right?
Or you may have a certain word, German.
Some of these words,
they don't have separators, right?
So they combined,
even I think Sanskrit also,
sometimes they may combine multiple
things.
Right?
So then how do you infer the meaning or
come up with the alternative set of words,
group of words for a certain specific
word in one language?
So basically the point is there are a lot
of challenges,
which some of which are dealt with in the
current approaches,
but some of them are still left open.
Okay,
now coming to the typical approaches.
By the way, are you guys with me?
I hope you're not. Yeah, okay.
Coming back to the...
Okay.
Okay, yes, is there a doubt?
Thank you.
Is there a doubt?
No, ma'am, not so far.
No.
OK, yes, OK. Coming to work wise,
just give me a second, sorry.
Okay, coming to the,
this one of these diagrams is a very
standard kind of a diagram where
basically this is a approach that is,
these are actually this,
you can look at it like a,
it's like a must diagram in any machine
translation session that you see across
any of the universities,
including Stanford and all.
So they'll start off with this
triangle,
where it shows the approaches of
translation.
Like it's kind of a history and where we
have come to.
So we started off with a simple direct
translation, word to word translation,
just like we do when we learn a language.
Sorry. So this is like you take up a word,
matching word, and you translate it.
So it's not grammatically correct.
It may not be semantically correct and so
on.
We just randomly pick up some words and
you do the translation.
It's the simplest mechanism,
easiest with least number of resources.
And of course,
the accuracy is going to be worst.
Then coming to the second one,
which is the syntactic,
where you ensure that the grammatical
structure.
So here also you will see there are two
steps.
One is natural language understanding
that you see on the left hand side,
this side,
and this is your natural language
generation. So every, as I told you,
NLP application has two components,
understanding and generation.
So understanding,
you're going to understand the input text
and generate,
you're going to generate in the
respective languages that you want to
translate. So when you're doing syntactic,
you have to ensure that the language in
which you're translating,
the grammar of that language is strictly
followed.
So that's the syntactic translation.
Now coming to the semantic.
This SRL is statistical relational
Learning and word sense disambiguation.
So you need to disambiguate correctly.
For example, bank,
whether it is in the context of river or
whether it is in the context of finance.
Depending on that, semantically,
the translation should be correctly done
in another language.
So,
all this was possible using these
statistical approaches, but this last one,
which is interlingua,
wherein you can translate automatically
from any language to any language,
irrespective of the grammar and so on.
This was a dream,
which is today come true by use of the
neural network approaches.
So using neural network approaches,
you are able to translate from any
language to any other language.
I'll talk about this shortly,
but this is what we are doing today using
the neural machine translation approaches.
So this was your simple approach,
which was direct transfer,
where you directly translated from one
language to another. Again,
it's not that simple because you need to
focus on the alignments here.
So when you're translating,
you may have to swap the order of the
words.
Okay,
so this lexical ordering also is a part
of it. Morphological, I told you already,
there are morphologically rich languages,
so that also needs to be taken care of
and so on. Syntax based,
I already told you,
so you can use the concept of parsing
that we studied in our NLP course.
to come up with the grammar of a language
and correctly do the grammatical
translation. Other than that,
semantic for semantic,
you may have to do the contextual word
embedding. So today, for semantic,
they do use the word embedding concept to
know whether the words are semantically
lying in the same space to do the
translation.
So again,
this is done by both the approaches by
using the simple string matching or by
using the word embeddings.
Coming to the current approach of neural
networks. So currently,
because of this neural network
translations,
Just give me a second.
I.
ADNAN.
So, this sorry,
I just drank the whole cup of tea.
Just give me a second,
I'll just drink water.
Okay, so.
This neural network translation,
the beauty of this approach is that the
earlier approach is still now statistical
machine translation approaches.
They required the corpora,
parallel corpora.
Parallel corpora is something like this.
Let me just show you that so that you can
understand.
Yeah,
so this is something like parallel
corpora. Now,
this is not this is a toy corpus,
not the real world corpus,
but typically you will have a sentence in
one language and a corresponding
translation in another language.
This is called as a parallel corpora. So,
parallel corpora is required for all the
machine translation approaches, including.
..
neural machine translation.
But the beauty of this interlingual
neural network approach is that you may
not have the parallel corpora of a
particular combination of languages,
yet you will be able to do the
translation if you have the parallel
corpora of the combination.
What I mean is,
suppose I have a parallel corpora of
English to Japanese and Korean to English,
I can use this corpora for translating
from Japanese to Korean,
although I may not have the parallel
corpora of both of these.
languages.
So that's the beauty of this neural
networks. Of course, in the next session,
next week's session,
we will see how the neural network
algorithms are used for machine
translation.
But this was kind of a very good kind of
breakthrough for doing the machine
translation.
for a pair of languages which may not
have the parallel corpora. Okay,
so the history of the approaches,
I'm going to touch upon each of them
because although today most of them do
use LLM based and transformer
architecture,
yet there are some applications where the,
or rather if you look at the.
things, the evaluation,
the problems or the some of the
techniques that were used in statistical
are still used in transformer and LLM.
So it will definitely be useful to
understand these approaches as well. Also,
I just checked they do use hybrid.
So everywhere they may not use LLM,
they might use for some of this basic
translation.
say maybe greetings or something using
rule based, then some other basic things,
maybe using statistical and say complex
translations using LLM based to avoid the
use of resources and to increase the ROI,
right?
So therefore it is important to
understand each of them.
So rule based are the simplest,
easiest to implement with lowest
complexity.
as well as least amount of money
requirement. Statistical is, again,
it's a bit heavy on mathematical,
so it does need resources,
but still it is comparatively less
expensive than the attention or
transformer or LLM based models.
But of course,
transformer and LLM-based models give you
the highest accuracy.
So it's always a trade-off between cost,
accuracy, speed, and so on.
So coming to rule based,
it was very simple.
You just parse the sentence,
give this syntax of a particular,
give grammar rules of a particular
language, give some phrase dictionaries,
equivalent dictionaries.
So this is definitely very predictable,
interpretable,
and there is no training data.
at all which is required.
So the quality of the output is not
dependent on the input data at all.
It is completely dependent on the way
that you write grammar rules or whatever
lookup dictionaries that you have.
Of course,
limitations are it is expensive and
expensive to build manually and also.
the accuracy is not that good.
So coming to the statistical machine
translation. So statistical machine,
we are going to solve some problems by
the way.
This is data-driven and it scales across
multiple languages,
but of course it needs parallel corpora.
That is one of the challenges.
This is also true for neural machine
translation. You need parallel corpora.
And it cannot capture a long-range
fluency as good as the neural approaches.
OK, so we'll talk about these as well,
but the concept of translation model,
language model,
and all these probability are again going
to be used in the...
attention and the neural models as well.
Okay, now statistical by the word itself,
you can come to know it uses probability
statistics, right?
So it uses the concept of probability and
it uses something called as a parallel
corpora,
which I already showed you as an example.
It is also called as bytext.
So there are a lot of corporas which are
available even for Indian languages.
So even in Hugging Face,
you will find a lot of data sets which
are available for Indian languages,
even across domains.
So if you want legal domain,
medical domain,
any domain data sets are easily available
across multiple Indian languages.
So it's available in Bengali, Kannada,
Marathi, Hindi, a lot of languages.
the data sets are easily available. Okay,
so which you can use it for training and
even for your statistical machine
translation models.
So they are easily available and open
source,
so you can use them for your industry
applications. Also,
parliamentary government data sets are
also,
so European government also has a data
set in.
different European languages including
French, German and so on.
So these data sets are also available.
So,
what the core idea for statistical
machine translation is very simple: you
are predicting a translation. So,
for example,
I want to translate from French to
English. OK,
so given an English best given a French
sentence, sorry, you want to find the...
Best English sentence Y given a French
sentence X,
so it's a simple argmax posterior
probability of finding a particular
language sentence given another language
sentence. Now,
the way we do this using statistical
approach is extremely simple.
Sorry,
we just use the Bayes rule of prior
probabilities and the likelihood.
Prior is extremely easy to obtain using
any English corpus.
This is nothing but your language model.
OK, so you can use n-gram language models,
you can use neural language models,
any language modelling techniques can be
used here.
You can use small language models,
edge language models,
large language models.
So this is pretty simple to obtain.
But what about the likelihood?
Likelihood is called as a translation
model.
And this is the place where you need the
parallel corpora.
Because here we are predicting what is
the probability of an English sentence.
Given the French sentence,
so this is a likelihood,
and for this we need the parallel corpora.
We don't need the parallel corpora for
language modeling;
we need the parallel corpora for the
translation model. OK,
so this is learned from the parallel data,
so these probabilities are easily
computed using the...
Parallel Data.
Okay, it's not that easy.
I'll talk about it.
But one important problem here in the
parallel data computing is the alignment
problem.
So we'll talk about the alignment problem.
And based on the alignments,
there are various IBM models which are
used.
We are going to discuss about the
simplest IBM model.
The same model is extended
for the other higher grade phrasal level
alignments and so on. So the idea is same.
So we'll start off with simple because
for exam,
it's easier to solve problem using model
1 compared to model 5.
So we will and the same concept is,
I mean, applicable for all of these.
So it's enough to know one of them.
which is the IBM Model 1. Okay,
so basically what we need is we need the
parallel corpora, as I said,
and we need the source text,
one language text. Okay,
so both of these are going to help you in
your machine translation.
Parallel corpora,
we already looked at this particular
example.
For the other language model,
you can use any Wikipedia text,
any web corpus text, news,
any text can be used, right?
Or you can use the ready-made language
models. You don't even,
you need to train these probability
models.
So for when you want to learn from data,
there are certain challenges.
Particularly some languages do not have a
space. I told you, right? German,
this particular word, if you see,
this is actually a combination of these
two words, security policy.
Whereas if you look at only this word,
this is nothing but security, right?
So it gets a bit challenging, but these,
so you must have these alignments.
That this word is referring to these two
words, right? So,
this is where the alignment comes. OK,
so getting the probability for one to one
word is easy: house to HAQUE,
house to this particular, this is easy,
but when you have a.
group of words and interchanging.
So something like this, right?
So basically when you're doing this
likelihood,
what you need is the alignment between
the words and that is not so easy to
obtain manually as well as automatically.
And that is where that attention is all
you need paper came into existence. Okay,
so aligning these, which are these words?
So for example,
example,
here you can see that this word is
mapping to these two words. Okay,
and also the order of the words is
changed. Okay, so SVO, SOV,
that is also changed and number of words
which are mapping to the number of words
in another language is also changing.
Soni.
So that is 1 challenge of alignment. Now,
alignment is not that simple.
And getting these alignments need a lot
of data.
And we are going to use the expectation
maximisation algorithm to get this
alignment.
I'll shortly show you how to do that.
But this is your problem of alignment.
So here you can see that
There are also something like spurious
words,
which may not have any matching word in
another language.
That is another big challenge. Plus,
as I said,
there are two words mapping to one word.
There is a order change of the words and
so on, right?
So the alignment is nothing but.
correspondence between the words of 1
language to words in another language.
That is the alignment.
That's the definition of alignment.
And as I said,
some words do not even have counterparts.
So the word like lay doesn't have a
counterpart in English at all.
Right, or you can see that,
so this is one simple example where you
do not have a counterpart.
The other words are quite straightforward
with one-to-one mapping,
but there can be something like this,
where you have many words in one language
mapping to, so this is shown as a matrix.
Many words in one language is shown.
as mapping to this particular word.
Similarly, it can be other way round.
Many words in another language mapping to
a single word in English. So like this.
Okay, so it can be one to many,
it can be many to one. At the same time,
it can be too fertile where many words in
one language or complete sentence.
almost is mapping to a single word in the
input, right? Another challenge is, sorry,
many words in one,
mapping to many other words in another.
So it's a big problem.
Alignment is not so easy to get.
And IBM Model 1 came up with a strategy
to come up with these alignments.
Okay, using the parallel corpora.
So the parallel corpora is important here
to get the alignments. Okay,
so once I have the alignments,
I have the prior probability,
I can easily find.
So I actually removed that gory
mathematical formula because that's today
nobody uses that. People go for neural,
so that's why.
I have removed that gory formula,
but basically,
or I don't know whether I kept it. Yeah,
no, not this one, sorry.
Yes.
I removed it, I think. Yes.
So I'll show you that. Basically,
when you're trying to come up with the
posterior probability,
you do need the alignment.
I think I kept the simple one.
Let me just quickly show you.
So this we saw, right?
We want to predict the probability of an
English sentence given a French sentence.
Right, this is our problem. And for that,
I need to have the alignment between
English and French words.
So this posterior probability,
we divided into the prior and the
likelihood.
Prior we saw is the language model and
this is your translation model.
Now to get this,
why is it called as a noisy channel?
Noisy channel is because it
generates a noise, right?
So you will not get the translation first
time itself. It will be trial and error.
You will get a lot of translation and
then you will select the arg max to get
the best translation.
That's why it is called as a noisy
channel.
We are going to generate a lot of noisy
translations.
before we get the final argmax best
translation. Okay,
so language model is pretty simple.
You can do it using n-gram language
models or you can use it doing neural
language models.
Both of them can be used for your
language modeling.
It's not that difficult.
It's very easy to get. It's basically...
how frequently a set of words occur
together. So this is easy,
but getting the translation model is a
difficult challenge because you need to
do the alignment,
which words of 1 language are matching
with which words of another language.
So getting these alignments, okay,
is a challenge. This alignment.
is what we need to find out. Okay,
so alignment is also important when we
are doing the machine translation.
So here, for example,
if you have J words in one language,
so this is your alignment,
J words in French,
which are mapping to words in English,
right?
So these are your J equal to 9 words in
French,
which are mapping to 6 words in English.
in English.
So the way that the alignments is shown
is using this English. So don't worry,
you don't have to mug up this formula at
all. Anyway, it's a open book exam,
but mathematical problems on alignments
can be asked. So I'll show you that,
how to do the alignments. So basically,
when we are finding the...
translation model,
we need to worry about the alignment.
Alignment is very critical when you want
to do the translation. Now,
how do you come up?
Can you tell me how do you come up with
this trans alignments? Any idea?
How can you come up with these alignments
between the words? Can you think of it?
It's 430. Okay,
let's take a break after this.
Can you tell me why do you think
alignment is important?
You understood what is alignment,
all of you?
Yes or no?
Yes.
Yeah.
Yeah. So can you think of a mechanism?
Yes. Yes, please.
Mhm.
Kumari.
S.
Can I guess, man, so basically, yeah,
so basically it is taking a set of words
and finding out the best possible,
you know, from the corpus.
Correct, but how?
What is the probability highest
probability of that occurring in here?
Yes,
basically calculating the probability
from the parallel corpora,
how many times this word is appearing as
Mm.
this.
So using the parallel corpora
probabilities,
you can find out the possible,
you can predict the probabilities.
Of course, it may not be very accurate.
It entirely depends on your parallel
corpora.
If your parallel corpora is noisy,
you are going to get noisy output.
But if your parallel corpora is very good,
there is a high chance that you will get
these alignment probabilities. OK,
so we are going to use the IBM Model One,
a mathematical framework,
a very simple one,
to calculate these alignment
probabilities and come up with these
alignments, automatic alignments.
But before that, we can take a very quick.
..
break if you want or if you want I can
finish with the IBM model problem and
then we can take a break. It's up to you.
Let me know.
I'm OK either ways. Quickly,
you want to take a break and then look at
Brickman.
this mathematical problem? I'm OK anyways.
No problem.
We can take a break and then we'll look
at this simple problem and then we have
the evaluation. OK, sure.
Yes, ma'am.
OK, should be start?
Is everybody back?
We share the screen.
Okay.
Is everybody back?
I'm going to cover the problem of
expectation maximisation for word
alignment.
So basically we saw that for translation,
we need to have the alignment among the
words. Okay,
so what happens is when we have this,
getting this parallel corpora itself is a
big challenge.
So this is the parallel corpora.
one language sentence and it's matching
other language sentence, right?
So now on top of it,
we also want to have this kind of
alignment, which is this word is mapping.
Sorry, let me just take a pen. Basically,
this is mapping to this or whatever.
I don't know. This is mapping to this.
and this is mapping to this and so on,
right?
So we want alignment also like this.
So some two,
3 words may map here or the last word may
map here. We don't know, right?
So getting this is a not possible
solution manually.
We need to do these alignments
automatically.
And for doing this automatic alignment,
we use this expectation maximisation
algorithm,
wherein you know that expectation
maximization, what do we do?
We try to come up with some probability.
We start off randomly with certain
probabilities,
and then we maximise the probabilities
looking at the data.
That is what we do in the expectation
maximisation algorithm, right? So,
in the E step,
we come up with certain random alignments
or probabilities,
and then we maximise those looking at the
training data. So, let us,
so this is a dynamic programming
algorithms,
is also called as Bob-Welch algorithm
that you have been
using in your unsupervised learning,
right?
So let us see how to use it for with a
simple example.
We are going to look at IBM Model 1,
which is the simplest one.
The same algorithm is also extended for
the null generation,
which is for the blank words and so on.
Okay,
so the same algorithms can also be used
for this.
which I showed you one example where
Ellie did not have a matching English
word, right? So this case, null word.
Okay, so sorry.
So alignment can be any of this.
It can be a spurious word,
it can be a group of words.
So you can come up with all these
alignments using all of these IBM models.
But we are going to look at a very simple
one where we are not looking at the
phrasal alignments,
but one word to one word alignment.
The same can be extended for phrasal as
well,
but we are only going to focus on the
word to word alignment in this example.
And even the exam,
we can expect word to word alignment
problem. OK, so the same idea, as I said,
can be extended for phrasal as well.
So let us start with a simple example.
Suppose this is our parallel corpora. OK.
So we have two sentences,
which is 1 is greenhouse and the second
one is the house.
And this is your French translation for
both of these particular sentences in
English.
For simplicity and even in your exam,
it will be simple with two or three words
max for calculations.
So let us take for simplicity,
these are our training corpora,
and this is your translation that is
given to you.
Now we want to come up with the alignment,
whether this alignment is correct,
this alignment is correct,
or this alignment is correct,
this alignment is correct, and so on.
Okay, so we want to cheque that.
So for that,
we are going to initially start off with
uniform translation probabilities because
we don't know.
So this is the first expectation phase
stage where we are first going to have
all of these unique words in your columns
and these are your unique English words.
Initially,
we are going to start off with a uniform
probability of equal probability for all
of these words. So, since we have 3 words,
equal probability means one by three for
each of these words. OK,
now we are going to continue this for
finding the probability of alignments. OK.
So,
for checking the alignment of the French
for these sentences,
now we are going to the sentence level.
OK, so we want to cheque this probability,
whether green is mapping to Casa and
house is mapping to wordy. So,
this is first alignment that we want to
find out. So, the way we compute is...
We take,
we know that green to casa initial
probability,
what we started off was one by three. OK,
what is house to worde?
It is also house to worde is also one by
three, right? So,
we just substitute those. Now,
we are making a independence assumption.
that green to quasa,
whatever is the alignment,
is independent of the probability of
house to early.
We are making a simple independence
assumption and we are coming up with this
alignment probability of green to casa
and house to early. So that is 1 by 9.
Now, similarly,
we are also going to compute it for the
other possibility,
which is green to verde and casa to house.
Obviously,
since we started off with a uniform
probability initially,
we are going to get your same one,
one by three, one by three. Now,
the same thing we are also going to look
at for the second sentence.
which is the house to last, the La Casa.
Again, we are going to get 1 by 9, 1 by 9,
and so on.
So now how do we decide which is better?
Is this combination better or is this
combination better? Okay,
so this is what we want to figure out.
What is the correct alignment for this
given corpus?
So, first,
we are going to normalise these
probabilities across these two
combinations,
because these two are possible, right?
This is 1 possibility of alignment,
and this is second possibility of
alignment for these group of words,
so we are going to normalise across these
two probabilities, so therefore...
This probability normalised value is
going to be 1 by 9.
Divided by 1 by 9 + 1 by 9,
which is nothing but two by 9, right? So,
this probability is going to be 1 by two.
That means now we have the probability of
1 by two for green to casa and house to
worldy. OK,
so this is now updated probability for.
So this is the alignment probability
which is normalised for this one and this
one. So it's equal probability.
Right now we have the equal probability
for both of them. Similarly,
we are going to have it for the other one.
Now what we are going to do is this was
our initial expectation or assumption.
We started off with a equal probability
for all the words,
but looking at this data, OK,
we know that if you compare,
there is no word of the here, right? So,
actually, the the and word day.
This should have been 0 value,
because in your parallel corpora,
you don't have any word which is having
house to wording, right? Therefore,
this can be updated.
This table initial probability table can
be updated looking at this corpus as this
new table.
which we have here.
Looking at this updated probabilities,
we can update this initial whatever
expectation we started off with. Here,
we are going to update it by these values.
So here we saw that between green to
wordy, in this case,
we got one by two probability,
green to wordy.
We got one by two probability;
this alignment right is getting one by
two probability green 2 already, sorry,
this one.
Okay, so therefore,
here we are going to update these
probabilities looking at the training
data.
We see that there is no probability
between la and green.
There is no mapping between la and green.
Therefore, this is 0. Similarly,
we see that there is no mapping between
Verde and the, so, therefore, I'm sorry,
I may be making wrong pronunciation,
but I'm just trying to explain this
example in a very simple words. So,
this is also zero. Now,
if you look at the probability of green
and casa, again, you have this one by two,
therefore, this is 1 by two.
Similarly, if you look at house and verde,
now I'll explain this one,
how you get this one by two plus one by
two. Here,
the reason we get these two additions is
because in our training corpus,
there are two alignments of house to casa.
So, this is one.
And this is another one.
Therefore,
we have the alignment for both of these
is 1 by 2 plus 1 by 2. Okay,
for none other words,
you have two kinds of alignments.
For all other words,
we have only a single word alignment.
Therefore, house to la, if you look at it,
It is only once, house to la. Similarly,
casa to the is only once, this one, right?
Similarly for other words, la and the,
you have half, this one.
Right,
so these are your updated probabilities
after looking at the parallel corpora. OK,
so when you now again,
these have to be normalized,
just like we normalise these,
we have to normalise these.
The way we do normalisation is row wise
normalization.
That means this particular probability is
normalised across this row.
So one by 2 / 1 by 2 1 by two,
which is same as this. OK, similarly,
we are going to normalise for this one.
For this one, it will be one by two. OK.
We just write it down.
Divided by all of these,
so one by two plus one by two plus one by
two plus one by two,
that is nothing but two.
Right,
so if you add all of these four halves,
you are going to get two, right?
Therefore, this probability is 1 by 4.
Similarly, if you compute for this,
how is this coming?
This is 1 by 2 plus 1 by 2 is 1 and
divided by sum of all of these four is 2.
Therefore, you got this 1 by 2. Similarly,
1 by 2 divided by addition of all of
these is going to give 1 by 4.
Same way, here it is, numerator is 0,
so this is going to remain 0. OK,
similarly for this one,
it is going to be 1 by 2 + 1 by two
divided by 1 by 2 + 1 by two, which is 1,
1 by 2 + 1 by two is 1, right? Therefore,
this is remaining as it is.
This is also remaining as it is.
These are your updated probabilities from
whatever you started off with. Okay,
now you can actually, so there are like,
just like the gradient descent,
you can stop after a certain number of
iterations,
or you can stop when one alignment
probability is greater than the other.
So now we are going to,
after we update this expectation card
table word to word,
we are going to update the alignment
probabilities as well,
looking at this values.
So, from these values, now,
if you compute the probabilities,
green to casa is 1 by two,
and house to verde is 1 by 4. Therefore,
this probability is 1 by 8.
Similarly,
if we calculate the other combination,
green to verde, it is one by two,
and house to casa is also one by two.
Therefore,
this probability of alignment is 1 by 4.
Similarly,
you can do it for the other pair.
Okay, now if you see, again,
we need to normalise this across both of
these alignments.
So when you normalise it,
what you get is 1 by 8 divided by 1 by 8
plus 1 by 4, which is nothing but 3 by 8.
So this probability is 1 by 3.
And this probability is 2 by three,
so this is more, right?
This probability is more than this,
so you can say that this alignment is the
correct alignment. Similarly,
you can do it for the other pair,
and you can see that this is more,
therefore this alignment is higher.
this probability, sorry, is higher, right?
So that is how you can come up with the
alignment by looking at the training data.
So this is a simple example of IBM Model
1 to come up with a word to word
alignment by looking at the parallel
corpora. And this iterations can continue.
So you can again
add these values to this particular table.
So I can add 1 by 3 to green to casa and
then again I can add 1 by 3 to house to
word a day and continue this process.
Okay,
so this can be done for the third
iteration, 4th iteration and so on.
Or you can stop at a point.
Where one alignment probability is more
than the others? OK,
so this is a very simple example to
explain how the alignment can be achieved
among these sentences. Is it clear?
The IBM Model One example,
is it clear to all?
Should I move on to the evaluation?
Are you guys with me?
Ma'am, I have one doubt on that one by 4.
Can you explain it? How we get 1 by 4,
Yes, ma'am.
Which one? This one?
the house 1 by 4?
This one. OK, OK,
let me just go to this example here,
Ah, this one by full.
right? House one by 4. OK,
so this one you want to know? OK,
Yes, ma'am.
let me just explain. OK,
so this we actually normalise it across
the row. These values,
we normalise it across the row.
So, therefore,
this probability is 1 by two.
Divided by one by two,
which is this one plus,
so it's like softmax plus one by two plus
one by two is 1, right? This this part.
Right.
And plus this one.
So, that comes to two,
this half plus half plus half will come
to two, so it is 1 by 2 / 2,
that is nothing but one by four.
That is how you get this.
Okay.
Similarly,
you are going to do the same thing for
No.
1.
this one also.
Ram Mahadev.
Can you go to the previous slide?
Yes.
There, 1 by 2 + 1 by 2 for house and casa.
Why, ma'am?
Huh.
Yes.
You want this one? Okay,
this came from here.
So because we have house to casa,
this is half.
And we have here house to casa,
which is half.
Therefore, this scheme.
Combination of these two.
So they are repeated twice, so two times.
If it is repeated three times,
Correct, correct, correct.
three times.
Three times, correct, correct.
Okay.
I have one more question.
Why we select only row 2 only,
K.
Yes.
but row one also we have that
normalisation can do, right?
Yes, yes, row one is also normalized,
but it is remaining same, the values,
because it is half plus half.
We are normalising across all,
And.
so here also it is actually half divided
by half plus half,
Oh.
which is nothing but one.
Because this is 0, right? Last one,
so we normalise it for all.
Bulk.
Ohh.
Okay, okay. Thanks.
Okay.
Ohh.
Ma'am, can you go to the previous slide?
Me.
The previous way.
Ah.
No, no, no, that is the first.
Before this.
Yes, before this, there is a calculation,
right?
The first calculation that I am not
getting.
Ha.
This one.
Yeah, yeah, this one, this one, uh...
Okay, what calculation you're not getting?
The first one,
greenhouse and the Casa building.
Like how is coming 1 by 9, 1 by 3,
what into 1 by 3?
Ha, okay. Okay, sure, sure. I'll tell you.
So this is because initially we started
off with a uniform probability for all
the linkages.
So we started off with the one by three.
We have not seen this data, parallel data.
We are only having this unique vocabulary
of 1 language.
and unique vocabulary of another language.
So we make uniform assumption.
We say that every word is equally likely
a synonym or rather a translation to
another word. Okay,
so we start off with a uniform
probability, which is 1 by 3.
Now we want to cheque
the alignment of the words,
which are these two.
This is your one sentence language and
this is another.
So we want to confirm whether this is
good or this is good.
So when we compute this alignment,
because initially what we have assumed,
green to casa is 1 by 3 and house to
verde is also.
one by three. Okay,
so we make a independence assumption that
green to casa is not dependent on house
to verde and we just take,
so if I have to find out the probability
of these two words, joint probability,
I just compute the joint probability of
casa given green and verde given house.
And that is how I get this one by 9.
Similarly, yeah.
Ohh.
Sorry, I just sorry to interrupt,
but I didn't get the concept of taking
Yes.
the house when the actual English
sentence was the greenhouse.
No, there are two sentences.
This is 1 sentence and this is another
I made a miss somewhere.
sentence.
There are two sentences in your parallel
corpora.
This is one example and this is another
Hello!
example. There are two different examples.
I see, I see. OK, understand.
P.
Ma'am, here we are, while normalizing,
we are dividing by 2 by 9,
Okay.
but here we are not taking the sum of the
row, right? So how this 2 by 9?
So this is equivalent to normalizing.
So we are taking the scores.
This is for the alignments, this one.
This is for, this is for the,
here we don't have to normalise because
here if you, sorry, where is that gone?
Here we are starting off with initial
probabilities, right?
This is for the after.
Mhm.
alignment. Okay, this is for, yeah,
you don't need to. Yes, yes.
Okay, so in the first step,
we divide by 2 by 9. Okay,
so that is the sum of the two only. Okay,
and then go to the last one where 3 by 8
Correct.
Correct, correct.
is there.
One more next page, I think. Yeah, here,
here, how to buy it?
Huh?
Huh, this is a 1 by, yeah, 1 by, no,
this is from here, 1 by 8 divided by.
Again, Rosam.
Uh, I don't know whether it, yeah,
one by I don't know, okay,
let me take it here, one by 8.
Divided by 1 by 8 + 1 by 4, these two,
these two alignment.
So this is actually 3 by 8, no? These 2,
if you just multiply by two, yeah, yeah,
Yeah, yeah, that I got it.
yeah. So this is that denominator.
So here also we had taken that only.
Let me just show you here.
Here also, it was 1 by 9 plus 1 by 9.
These are alignment probabilities of the
sentences.
These are alignment probabilities of the
words. OK,
so here this is for the entire sentence.
We are normalising it by the.
One by 9 + 1 by 9 here,
and here we are normalising by these two,
1 by 8 and 1 by 4.
Clear.
Yeah,
so in between stage only we are taking
the sum of the row actually do divisual.
Yes, that is for the, yeah,
that is for this expectation step for
word to word alignment.
Okay.
Okay, okay, so lib.
translation between the words.
We did translation counts.
Got it, ma'am,
because I was trying to align all the
Mm.
Ha.
steps in line, actually,
which are not the true, actually. OK,
Ha ha.
got it, got it.
Okay.
In this in this corpora, there is 3 word,
right? So,
Uh-huh.
this is it we taking one by three,
because this is 3 word, right?
Huh.
one by three. If there is 4,
we will take one by 4.
OK, the greenhouse is the English word,
and this is one from a fresh word. OK.
Yes.
Correct, correct.
Please.
Sec.
Okay.
Okay, now let's come to the last topic,
which is evaluation.
Let's see what is the time we have time,
right?
Yeah, we have time. We have time,
lots of time actually. 530, right?
Half an hour, half an hour.
5 o'clock it is. Good, good.
So I will be able to cover this
evaluation example. Please focus.
I know it's end of day. 540. Yeah, yeah,
It is still 540.
Testing 5 for.
540 correct.
So we will easily be able to complete
this example.
This is also important because BLEU score
is a very commonly used mathematical
evaluation measure for statistical as
well as neural machine translation. OK,
also,
I'll touch upon some other evaluation
measures which are commonly used.
Evaluation, by the way,
is also a very important topic for all
the NLP Applications. The reason being...
Whenever you're developing a production
ready system,
it is very important to cheque the
performance with respect to benchmark
data sets,
with respect to your company data sets.
It is very important to evaluate the
system because only when you evaluate for
the accuracy or different things,
you will know whether whatever you have
implemented is good or not.
Therefore,
evaluation is important even in machine
translation. Now, obviously,
we know that human evaluation is going to
be the best,
but it is very time consuming and it is
resource intensive, right?
It's expensive and it will take a lot of
time if you have to evaluate, say,
millions of translations or millions
sizes of documents.
There are thousands of pages and if you
want to check, it is going to be tough.
So automatic evaluation is definitely a
good choice, but it's cheaper definitely,
but it may not be accurate, right?
So we are trying to map now how the human
beings do the evaluation with.
how the machines can evaluate the machine
translation system.
So there are multiple things that we look
at when we look at the machine
translation output.
As we discussed before,
fluency is important.
It should be grammatically correct.
It should be understandable.
It should be readable. Okay,
so that is one important thing.
Secondly,
it has to convey whatever is the actual
information in the original source
language.
You cannot translate it something
different.
That will mean something different, right?
So particularly in international
relations or even in business
communication,
you don't want it to infer something else.
That's also important.
It has to be faithful to whatever the
original language sentence is.
It has to be fluent,
grammatically correct, understandable.
It also needs to be adequate or
acceptable.
That means whatever information is there
in the source language,
all that information should be correctly
conveyed completely.
in the second language.
And it should also be informative, right?
So you must answer whatever are the
question.
It should give a proper information about
whatever is conveyed in that particular
language. So typically,
human evaluation will give more focus on
faithfulness as well as fuel.
fluency,
it has to be grammatically correct,
fluent, understandable is the first thing,
right? And secondly,
it should give you what it actually means.
So these are very important. Now,
there are challenges when we talk about
faithfulness.
There are multiple translations possible,
which mean the same, right?
So it gets a little challenging,
but nevertheless,
there are all these translations can set
to be correct. Okay,
so you can say that this Mary didn't slap
the green witch. Of course,
now if you say not give a slap to the
witch green,
you know that it's incorrect because it's
not grammatically correct, right?
Or green witch didn't slap Mary.
I don't know whether it's a correct
translation, although it's kind of...
giving information where it did not,
what it did not happen,
but it's also not conveying what should
happen, what did happen, right?
So therefore,
and this is totally maybe opposite.
First one is probably correct,
didn't slap. The second one is probably,
this is totally opposite meaning, right?
So.
It has to be fluent and it has to be
faithful. That is very important.
Now,
what are the different automatic
evaluation metrics which are commonly
used for machine translation? Of course,
accuracy and all we have already seen,
but they are not directly suitable for a
machine translation problem.
Because in machine translation,
you have to cheque the words.
You cannot just say that this word is
correct, this word. I mean,
there has to be semantic meaningfulness.
There has to be a group of words which
are mapping to the translation.
So it's not as direct as precision.
We'll still see how the precision can be
used and what are the challenges of it to
use in machine translation.
We'll talk about that.
And then we'll look at the blue measure,
evaluation. NIST is not there, but blue,
we will talk about it.
That's a very commonly used evaluation
measure in machine translation. So first,
let's look at a simple evaluation measure,
which is traditionally used in across
machine learning and deep learning.
So here,
It's a very simple way of calculating.
So basically,
we are going to look at all the possible
words in our reference translation,
and we will look at the possible words in
our candidate translation.
That means reference is given by the
human, which is a good translation.
So it's like your.
actual data and candidate is what is
predicted by the system, right?
So you want to cheque how many words in
the candidate are matching with the words
in the reference translation.
So candidate is what your system has
generated.
So you see that first is absolute.
I mean, it doesn't make sense at all.
It has just generated word the multiple
number of times.
The second one is pretty good.
It is at least giving the words.
It is giving the cat is mad on.
At least the words are coming,
which are matching with the actual
reference translation.
So the reference is given by the human.
which is the cat is on the mat.
So this is the translation maybe for some
French sentence or English sentence that
is given by the human beings.
Now we want to validate the quality of
our candidate translations.
Now if you look at the first one,
it has the word twice.
So precision is just counting.
the number of words that are occurring in
reference and the number of words that
are occurring in candidate.
So if you look at the precision for the
candidate one,
it is going to be 2 by 7 because seven
are the total words in the reference and
two of them are appearing in the
candidate one. So the precision is 28.5%.
Now, interestingly,
when you look at the second candidate
translation, again, there are 7 words,
and all of these words are occurring in
the reference translation.
So it is giving you 100% precise.
And if you look at the sentence,
it is gibberish.
You cannot understand the meaning because
the cat is on.
is bad the on doesn't make any sense at
all, right?
So grammar plays a very important role,
which is not captured here and therefore
absolute precision measure or accuracy
measure is not suitable for machine
translation evaluation.
And therefore we have, yes.
UMANG.
No, I have a doubt,
like you're saying a reference is given
Yes.
by human, right?
The cat and the candidate too,
Get it.
there is 6 words, right, not 7.
One, two, three, 4, 6, 6.
Ohh.
Yes, yes, you are right. Yes, yes.
There are, yeah, yeah, yeah. It is 6 by 6.
Yeah, so, yeah, so firstly, you can.
Yes, it is 6 by 6. Both of them are,
you are right.
Okay, 6 verses.
Thank you for pointing that out.
Here it is 7 in the candidate,
candidate translation.
So, denominator is candidate words.
Mm-hmm.
When can we count that the stop like a
full stop also, or we can?
Yes, yes,
those are also important at a full stop.
That's a good point.
So here they have actually looked at only
Yeah.
the words. But yes, you are right,
maybe the full stop can also be
considered, then it will be 6 by 7. Still,
that precision is high.
Yes.
Even if you look at the, yeah, even.
No, ma'am, in that case,
the first one becomes 8.
The in that case.
First one will be division by 8, then dot.
First one.
First one, I have three, uh,
because dot full stuff has.
8, yes, correct.
So it will further reduce now. No,
Mhm.
this will further reduce.
I'm talking about this one.
Yeah.
This will become 7 by 6.
Yes.
Yeah, so.
Well, one thing I'm not getting,
the candidate one, the other is 2 times.
Yes.
So you're saying 2 by 8,
2 by 7 or whatever it is,
if I'm not considering the full stuff,
2 by 2 by 7.
Yeah, so it is taking repeated words.
Repeated words are taken.
Yeah.
Unique words are not considered.
It is repeated words.
Two by 7.
The reason is because even in the
sentence, when you are translating,
Right, so two-time.
Okay.
it is likely that I have multiple times
articles.
So articles are also important when you
do the translation.
So in machine translation, stop words,
articles, all these full stop, et cetera,
may play a very important role.
Right,
and I'm not getting the position for the
candidate two, like, how is it two is 1?
This one can spin.
Ha.
Yes,
so actually it is taking 6 words divided
by 6. Let me just show you again.
So if we ignore the full stop, okay,
ignoring the full stop,
don't look at the full stop as of now.
Mhm.
Just ignore the full stop.
If you look at the words, they are one,
two, three, 4, 5, 6.
So your reference translation words are 6
and total number of words in candidate
Right.
are again 6, one, two, three, 4, 5, 6.
So therefore 6 / 6 is 1.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, you got it, got it, thank you.
Yeah, so ignoring the full stop, yeah,
ignoring the full stop,
And.
we get this values. Six by 6 is 1,
and this is 2 by 7.
Thank you.
Sec.
And if we don't ignore,
then also we'll get the same values.
No, right, man.
One second. Yes, it will be 3 by 7. Three,
I don't know, it will slightly change.
Play, bye.
So here,
if we take the full stop as one of the
words, then this will become 3 by 7,
3 by 8.
Yeah, yeah, for the first one, it will,
yeah.
For first one it will change,
for the second one it will.
And for this one,
it will be actually 7 by 6.
No,
number of candidate translation occurring
in difference. So that would be 6 only.
Yeah,
so candidate translation words are 7 if
you consider, sorry, it will be 6 by 7.
Stop.
Yes, you are right. It will be 6 by 7.
No, 6 by 6.
No, it will be 6.6, 6.6, madam.
Megan.
If you consider the full stop.
Total number of words in the candidate
translation are six only.
There is no full stop in candidate 2.
It's only 6 by 6.
Yeah, yeah, so I had, yeah,
7 by 6 is more correct, yes.
If 6 about 6.
Ohh.
It is 6 by 6 for candidate two.
I'm 76 only Kanaparthi.
No, no, see,
if you consider the full stop for
candidate two,
the number of candidate translation words
in reference are okay. Yeah,
it will be 6 only, yes.
Six.
Six by 6.
Yes, only words is mentioned. Actually,
it's not mentioned.
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes, correct, correct, correct.
So I think it's better to ignore the
punctuation. Anyway, in the exams,
I will specifically mention if a full
stop needs to be considered or not,
but otherwise you can ignore it and write
the assumption ignoring the full stop.
Okay.
So anyway,
precision is not used by the way.
Right.
BLEU score is used.
This is just to show you the problems of
precision. So this is giving you 100%,
but it is not a good translation.
We want a proper syntactic translation,
right?
So although we are saying that this is a
very good, highly precise translation.
Obviously, this is not a good translation.
So precision is in fact,
if you use plain precision measure,
it is not used at all in machine
translation. In machine translation,
people go for BLEU score,
which is bilingual evaluation under study.
We'll talk about this. Yes.
Somebody was saying something.
Was it regarding? Yeah.
No, ma'am, that is that is clear now.
Actually,
we are not using current scenarios, yeah.
OKOK.
Yes, yes.
So we are going to use this blue score.
Again,
here we do have the reference translation,
which is given by the human annotate
translators and the candidate translation,
which is generated by the machine.
Now we are going to compute,
we are going to check.
How good is our automatically generated
machine translation compared to the human
translation?
So let us see the steps. First,
let me show you an example.
Then we will look at these steps.
It will be easier to understand that way.
OK, so let's look at the example first.
I will show you these steps again. OK,
so let us say that now in this case,
it is reverse than the others.
In the earlier example,
we saw we had multiple
Candidate and one reference. Now,
in this example,
we have multiple reference which are
given by the human beings.
It is possible human beings may give one
or more translation depending on what is
the candidate sentence. Okay,
so in this example,
we are assuming that we have...
Three good human translations available,
and this is the one that is generated by
your system. So,
this is your system generated,
and these three are the reference human
translations. OK,
so now we are going to compute the BLEU
scores using these.
reference human translation for the
candidate translation.
So first step is to count each n-gram in
the candidate. Very simple.
And you are also going to calculate the
multiple occurrences. So for example,
love is occurring three times, but love,
other, love.
friend for love yourself.
So 3 times love is occurring.
So you are going to note the total number
of occurrences for each of the words.
Now we are going to compute the total
words, including the duplicates.
How many total words are there in the
candidate translation?
That is the first step, very simple.
The reason I'll tell you later on why we
need to also,
instead of calculating the total,
why do we note down the occurrence?
Because we are going to need these counts
in the next step.
That is the reason we note down the
individual word counts in the second step.
It is again a very simple step.
What we are going to do, please be,
I mean, please focus here.
We are only going to look at the words
which are present in the candidate
translation. So the words like but, sorry,
but love other friend for yourself.
These words
You are going to cheque how many times
they are occurring in each of the
reference translation,
and we are going to note down the
reference count where it appears maximum
number of times. So,
in the first reference, if you look at...
you have but once, right?
Even in the second you have but once,
third also you have but once.
So the maximum number of times but is
occurring in any of the translations is 1.
So therefore it is 1. Okay,
please remember that we are only looking
at the candidate words. So here,
although we have the word thyself,
We are not counting that because that is
not present in the candidate translation.
Okay,
so we are only looking at the words in
the candidate translation first.
So here in the reference count,
now we calculated the word but.
Now let's look for the word love.
Now when you look at these three
references, okay,
we are looking at the reference count.
So love is occurring once here,
love is occurring once here,
and love is occurring twice in the
reference 3. And as I said before,
we are going to pick up the count of
maximum occurrence.
So in the third reference, we have twice,
therefore we are picking up that.
Similarly,
we are going to look for the word other
because that's present in the candidate.
Now, in all the three references,
what we have,
none of them have the word other.
Therefore, it is 0.
Similarly,
all these three references do not have
the word "friend"; therefore, it is zero.
What about the word for?
For is appearing here twice. Sorry.
OK, so therefore we have here two.
Similarly, what about the word yourself?
Yourself is appearing once,
here also once, here also once. Therefore,
the count is 1.
Okay,
so that's how you are going to do the
reference counts.
You have done the candidate counts,
reference count.
Now the third step is you are going to
clip.
That means you are going to pick up the
count with minimum among the reference
and the candidate count.
So for each of these words of the
candidate,
You are going to clip it to the minimum
value, so here for but it is one for both,
here also it is one, here also it is one,
so we are going to have the minimum value
as one. Similarly, for the word love,
we are having this twice and this in the
reference, sorry,
in the candidate we have.
Three times,
and in reference we have two times,
so you are clipping to the lower value,
which is 2 for the word other,
it is not appearing in any of the
references, so the minimum count is 0.
Similarly for the word friend,
for the word for,
it is appearing twice in the reference
and once.
in the candidate, so minimum is 1.
So basically,
you're taking the minimum among the
reference and the candidate count. OK,
that is how you get this clip count.
Now, the way we compute the blue score,
a simple blue score. By the way,
this is not the final blue score.
This is the first step in the blue score.
So we are going to take this clip count,
which is five,
which is nothing but the total of these 1
+ 2 + 0 + 0 + 1 + 1 is going to give you
5.
So the blue score,
which is a naive blue score,
is nothing but the clip count, which is 5,
divided by the total count, which is 8.
Okay, so this is the naive blue score,
but this is not going to be the final
blue score. Okay,
so this is your blue score,
which is telling you the quality of the
translation.
which is 5 by 8. OK, now this is for now.
OK, this we talked about the blue,
whatever calculations we saw where for
the single n-grams, one gram.
We know that we have bigram, trigram,
and so on, right?
So this here we have considered one word
at a time.
And we have done these computations for
individual words in the reference
translation and individual words in the
candidate translation. OK, same thing,
we can repeat it for the bigram, trigram,
and so on. OK,
so we are going to look at a simple
example of...
Unigram and bigram. OK,
so this is your unigram. So,
using these steps,
can you compute the BLEU score for
unigram for this particular example?
Do all the steps and calculate it.
You understood all the steps.
The first step is count unique words.
How many times?
Second step is count a reference,
whichever is appearing maximum.
Then third step is clip.
And then 4th is just divide the clip by
the total words in the candidate.
So, please do for this.
Now,
I have a question on the previous slide.
And one of...
Yes, please, yeah.
In the reference count,
we took the max here, right?
What is the rationale behind taking
maximum there?
Yes.
And then what happens if we just go with
the usual count?
Actually,
we could have taken minimum also,
but then this clip count will vary.
Instead of two, we would have got three.
This is showing how many overlaps are
there between the reference and the
candidate. So more the overlap,
the better is the translation.
You want more overlap between the
Okay.
reference and a candidate.
That is the reason we take this more
maximum.
Thank you.
Sizzles.
Which mean right, so total 6.
One, two, three, yeah.
Six, right? Now,
let's look at the reference. Mary,
how many times maximum you have once?
No, how many?
So I'm just writing reference counts
below this line.
So no is appearing anywhere. No, right?
Okay.
It's not appearing. So zero.
What about slap ones? The ones.
Yeah.
Okay.
Which ones and green also ones.
So clip is.
You.
Five by 6.
What? Five by 6?
Man, the score is 5 by 6, yeah, point.
That.
How 5? You take the minimum.
Yeah, so one needs, so yeah.
Mm.
Zero, correct. Yeah, right, 5 by 6,
correct.
Zero only.
All the songs.
Five over six months.
Yes, 5 / 6, right? So,
that's the nine blue score with unigram.
Now,
let us look at the same example with
bigram. Oh, sorry.
Just give me a second.
It's okay, I should. Yeah.
Now this is another example with actually
unigram only, I think. No,
this is for the same example with bigram.
Okay,
let me just explain you quickly for this
and the next one you can do it. So here,
instead of looking at the unigram counts,
what we saw before for the candidate,
Now what you're going to do is you're
going to look at 2 words together.
Mary know, no slap, slap the, the which,
and which green.
The advantage here is it will give you
the phrasal alignments also.
And another thing is this is also keeping
in track.
the order of the words. Okay,
so that's one advantage of this blue
score. Also,
the order of the words will be important.
So which green is not same as green which.
Okay, so when you compare these two words,
which green, it's not same as green which.
Okay,
so that's also one important advantage of
blue score.
So, here in this, when you take bigram,
there are one, two, three, 4, 5 bigrams.
Usually it is N minus 1.
So if the total number of words are 6,
the number of bigrams that you will have
is N minus 1, which is 5. Okay,
you can cheque it,
validate it that manner.
Now the same concept,
we are going to do it for reference.
We are going to look at 2 words at a time.
OK,
so if you look at 2 words at a time here,
Mary no is not occurring,
so we are not looking at a single word
now, we are looking at 2 words, so zero,
right? What about no slap?
It is again zero,
because no word is not there.
What about slap though? It is one.
Right, what about the green?
It is 0 because you don't have the green
in the quartus, you have the witch, so...
The witch, the witch, not the girl.
Though.
Yeah, so that's why this is 0.
The witch, not the gun.
Again,
which green is also zero because we are
looking at the order of the words, right?
So now if you look at the clip count,
it is going to be 1 by 5.
One is the clip count, right? Minimum one,
and this is also occurring one,
and your reference is also occurring one.
So it is going to be one by 5.
For the bigram, for the unigram,
it is 5 by 6, for the bigram,
it is 1 by 5.
Okay, so in practical scenarios,
the way you compute is you take the
unigram as well as bigram.
Sometimes you also take the trigram. Okay,
all the three are considered and then the
average.
A average is not a simple average.
I'll show you that the way that it is
computed.
So same way you can do it as a homework
since we don't have time now.
You can, if we get time,
we can do it at the end of the class.
But this is another example to compute
the bigram and the unigram probabilities.
I have given the values,
but you try to compute it yourself and
validate it whether it is coming
correctly for you. Okay,
so now the way that it is computed in
general in the practice.
scenario, the blue score,
is by looking at the combination.
So for each of the candidates,
so we saw that this was one candidate
that was generated by the system and this
is another candidate. Okay,
so for each of the candidates,
now we want to compare which is better.
Okay,
so maybe system one has generated
candidate one and system two has
generated candidate 2.
So I want to cheque whether system one is
better or system 2 is better.
I'm going to do it using the BLEU score
measure. Okay,
so the way that we do is we compute.
So I told you that you take the
combination of unigram and bigram.
Right,
so unigram was 5 by 6 for the first
candidate, and bigram was one by 5. So,
you combine both of these scores for
candidate one and compute the blue score
by taking the square root.
The reason is because you're taking
unigram and bigram. If...
you were also taking the trigram,
then it would have been cube root of the
three things. OK,
so this will depend on how many products
you are taking.
So here you are taking two products,
unigram and bigram. Therefore,
we are taking square root. If it was 3,
then it would have been cube root. OK,
so right now we are computing this for
each of the candidates. Sorry.
So for this,
you get 5 by 6 multiplied by 1 by 5.
Square root of that is this value.
Similarly for the 2nd,
I did not calculate it,
but you can do it as a homework for the
second sentence.
The same way you can compute the unigram.
And so this is your unigram and this is
your bigram.
for the second one. So again,
I'm computing the combined precision or
BLEU score for this using these.
The reason we use P here,
I'll tell you later,
because this is also not the final BLEU
score.
Final BLEU score also considers the
length of the translation,
because that is also important.
The length of the translation also is an
important factor in computing the BLEU
score. Okay.
I'll tell you the reason also why we do
that.
So this is combining the bigram and the
unigram,
which gives you a better evaluation for
comparing the machine translation.
Now,
there is one concept called as brevity
penalty, which is given as a value for,
so this is like a penalty that is given
if the reference translation is, sorry,
if the candidate translation is shorter
than the human translation that is given.
references your human translation.
If your candidate translation is smaller
or shorter than your reference,
then you give a penalty.
That is called as a brevity penalty.
And that penalty is computed in this
manner,
which is E raised to 1 minus R by C. Now,
don't ask me this because this is from
the research paper,
how you get this formula.
But this formula is basically going to
give a penalty to a translation if that
translation is smaller than the reference
translation.
This is actually considering the sentence
length. OK, so you want to penalise if,
because otherwise,
if you just look at the scores.
We are nowhere considering the size of
the translation.
So if the size of the translation is
small,
you may end up getting a higher BLEU
score,
although that translation may not be that
good. Okay, so therefore,
we take this brevity penalty into
consideration to consider the size of the
candidate translation.
And as I said,
if the candidate translation length is
more than the reference,
you do not give any brevity penalty.
You just multiply it by one.
But if the candidate is smaller,
then you need to multiply it by this
factor,
which will further reduce your BLEU score
or BLEU precision.
with this brevity penalty. Okay,
so here you can see an example.
So this is our candidate one translation.
Again, for this,
you need the best reference because if
you have multiple references,
it is difficult to find out which is to
compare the length.
So among the references,
if you have the best reference,
it's easier to compute or you can assume
a certain reference to be a best
reference.
reference and then compute this brevity
penalty.
So here you can see that the candidate
words,
number of words are six and the reference
are seven. Therefore,
the brevity penalty has to be assigned
because this is less than this one and
that is given by raise to 1 - 7 which is
reference.
Length divided by the candidate length,
and you get this smaller score,
so you can see that this brevity penalty
is reducing your precision value. Earlier,
it was 0.4, now it is 0.3, 0.34, right?
So it's reduced, so you are penalizing.
if at all your candidate is length is
smaller than the reference. Whereas here,
if you see,
the candidate is much more longer.
Therefore,
you are giving brevity penalty as one.
That means you are not penalising and
therefore,
your BLEU score is remaining as it is.
Right, so from these two,
you can conclude that candidate two is a
better translation. OK,
or system is a better system.
Okay,
so that is one of the ways that you can
Mhm.
calculate the BLEU score and compute the,
I mean,
do the evaluation of a machine
translation system.
Is the BLEU score calculation, brevity,
penalty, etc. clear to all?
Okay.
Is there any doubt? What is the time?
Or, if the...
Yes.
I shouldn't understand the logic behind
this penalty map.
Ha, okay. Let me tell. Yes, I'll tell you.
Yes. So the reason we give the penalty is,
What is the intention of?
so if you look at,
so suppose I have a very short
translation,
what will happen is the candidate,
it's a denominator, right?
So let me just show you what I mean.
So here, if the, in the denominator,
Yeah.
you have the number of words in the
candidate.
Where is that, Pandey? Yeah.
This way.
Right, so if this is 4,
your score is going to be higher,
Ohh.
understood? That is why.
Correct, correct, correct. Okay, okay,
got it.
Sec.
OK, all the steps, yeah.
Can I check? Yeah, I just want to ask,
so basically what level of what blue code
is acceptable as a right translation?
Because what we need is actually...
That's a difficult question. Highest,
like 90%, 99%. It depends on your system,
right? So like if you have 99, it is best,
right? 99%.
Yeah.
So you set a threshold where we can say
that, okay,
now the machine has probably translated
it correctly or something of that scope.
So that's what it depends on your
application.
So if you are okay with some mistakes,
then you can be happy with 80% PLEU score.
Yeah.
Okay.
Otherwise, if you want 100% and 99.
99 or whatever, right?
So it depends on your requirements.
A 100% is what is expected.
You want it to be fluent as well as
grammatically correct.
So this might be ensuring both.
Okay.
Or on I like that.
I mean,
if you're as close to the reference,
if you're able to give exactly same as
reference, your task is solved, right?
Mm.
I mean, so that is what it is.
100% is the best.
Or on a lighter way,
unless and until your end user doesn't
Okay.
complain, you're good.
Mmh.
S.
Yeah, makes sense, valid.
That is the right score.
Yeah.
Yeah, good point. Yes.
So I hope BLEU score is clear to all.
Anything, any doubt in that?
I think that was the last. Actually,
there are other measures which are used,
Yes.
but BLEU score even today in the neural
machine translation is the most popular
one.
So this is the best measure that is used.
There is NIST,
so there are some minor issues with BLEU
score also.
What happens is sometimes they may not
correlate and so some limitations of blue
score are covered up by some other
measures. I'll take it up next time,
but there are some measures.
Let me see if I have in another slide
deck, otherwise I'll show it next time.
But there are some measures of blue score
if you look at it.
There are stop words, right?
So among these words,
let me just show you what I mean.
I'll take it up again next time,
but let me just explain what I mean.
So here, for example, let's take, okay,
since we have time,
we'll take the second example also.
So here, if you look at it, sometimes,
The priority might be for the words like
green witch and so on.
They should be so more importance should
be given to the main words in the
sentence for translation compared to
maybe the stop words and so on.
So you want to give more weightages for
correct translation for the.
what to say. I'll call them as open words,
which are like your nouns or your
adjectives rather than the stop words.
Of course, for grammatical correct.
So it's like fluency versus faithfulness.
So you might want more importance for the
faithfulness than the fluency,
that is grammar.
Okay,
so those are some kind of a tweaking for
the BLEU score. Also, instead of,
so here we saw that when we compared,
when we calculated these candidate words,
reference words,
we looked at the strings of the words.
So instead of that,
people also use word embedding.
So they do use BERT scores.
So that is also one of the evaluation
measures.
So the similar idea of the BLEU score is
implemented,
except instead of looking at these
strings or the words as a whole,
as letters,
you look at it like a word embedding,
mathematical vector conversation.
and then do the comparison.
That's a little bit more complex.
I'll talk about it in the next session,
but that's also one of the measures which
is popularly used in machine translation.
But BLEU scores,
as far as I saw most of the research
papers even today,
which are using transformers or LLM
models, still use BLEU score as a
standard evaluation measure for
evaluating machine translation systems.
I just wanted to highlight. Yeah.
I have a trouble.
I have a doubt.
So here like reference is passing by the
human human right reference word and the
candidate candidate is also passing by
Yes, yes.
human or candidate is like.
No, no, no.
Candidate is what is generated
automatically by your machine translation
system using neural or statistical
Okay.
measure,
whatever automatically your system is
generated and references what human
beings have given.
So it's like predicted and the actual.
Right.
Okay, got it.
And this blues course is fine with
English language is fine,
but it is possible that is also playing a
Ohh.
Indian.
role in Hindi or other Indian language or
is not.
Ah, Indian languages also,
they use blue score.
They do use because words are in Hindi,
that's it. So you,
but you must have the reference in Hindi.
You cannot compare reference in English
Ohh, okay.
Okay, okay.
with candidate in Hindi. You have to,
so that's a challenge.
Right, right, right, right.
We'll talk about Indian machine
translation. There are a lot of.
for scope for research as well as a lot
of opportunities there.
We'll talk about it. As I said,
I'll also try to pitch in if I can get
Yeah.
somebody from AI for Bharatesh.
Let me see.
Basically, what I understand,
the thing is that we are calculating the
Mam.
math. Underline is all math,
the calculation. So fine, what is fine,
Yeah.
like an English speaker sentence that you
can walk, right?
Mm.
So we are translating to the basically
transforming to the ratio or the math.
Is the underline the math,
so it can also possible, I think, right?
Right.
Right, right. Yeah, you can.
It's just the words, right?
OK, OK.
Good.
Even if you look at,
that's why word embedding,
you can also do cross language.
So word embedding will give you the
vector representations.
So those are also one of the techniques.
That's why I said next time I'll show you
the word embeddings also,
how they are used.
for machine. So basically,
neural machine translation is all about
word embeddings.
So today we talked about alignment
Mmhmm.
problem,
we talked about evaluation measures,
we talked about the applications and the
statistical machine translation.
Next session,
we'll focus on how transformers,
LLM models, et cetera,
are used for machine translation.
And we may also talk about some of the
advanced evaluation measures. And last,
third,
so we have three contact sessions on
machine translation.
One is giving the general orientation,
applications, issues, evaluation, etc.
The second one is focusing on how LLM
models, transformers, etc.
are used for machine translation.
And the third one will be focusing
completely on Indian machine translation.
The reason I included this Indian machine
translation because it was suggested
somebody from Google and Microsoft both.
So they said there is a lot of work going
on and there is a lot of scope for
research. So please include these.
So that's why I've included that.
one of the contact sessions focusing on
Indian machine translation.
That is also interesting.
So,
when we're talking about when we're
talking about the Indian translation,
it will like Hindi to Tamil,
Telugu is possible, right?
Yeah,
it can be English to Hindi as well as
Hindi to Marathi, Hindi to Tamil, Hani to,
I mean,
it can be within Indian languages across
Hindi to French, those also.
Okay.
Yeah.
Actually,
it is applicable even for German to
French and not just Indian.
I'm calling it on Indian because I'm
Mhm.
going to focus and I'm going to tell a
lot of about Indian languages from AI for
Bharatesh and so on,
because a lot is happening today in that
area.
But it is same concept is applicable for
any language to any language.
HITESH.
Okay, thank you.
You said it,
are you going to also are you also going
SONI.
to discuss about machine translation as a
part of rack pipeline for example?
Ha, we can do that. Yes,
I can discuss that as well.
So, is that?
Okay.
That's a good idea.
We can discuss that also.
Ohh, come on.
OK, thanks.
Yes.
Another general question.
So I was working on this chunking and
Yes.
getting the pipeline.
So is there a generic thumb rule on the
Huh.
size of the chunk or is it to be found by
trial and error?
So I can go from anywhere between 10 to
500 as a chunk size. So.
Understood, understood, understood.
So there are guidelines. In fact,
today we could not cover that.
We have that as some guidelines are given
Okay.
for chunking. But again,
it depends on the application.
So there are guidelines.
So cost is also a matter, right?
Okay.
Mmhmm.
Mm.
Correct.
No.
On the other hand,
also larger chunks might involve a lot of
memory as well as tokens.
So you need to balance.
Exactly.
So there are some guidelines on chunking,
which I was supposed to talk today in
conversational AI,
but I'll cover that in the next session.
OK, OK, OK. Thanks.
Yeah. Okay. Thank you. Yeah. Yes.
In blue score, like we have them for one,
one gramme and two gram.
When we take the three gram,
if we get zero,
Huh?
then the total score would be zero, is it?
No,
then you should not consider trigram
because, yeah,
you should not consider trigram if none
We should not consider.
of them, zero, zero,
I'm just thinking whether you will get
zero because numerator can be, huh,
reference, nothing is there,
Because 2 ground, we got one by N.
you are saying in the candidate.
Yeah, yeah.
It is possible as a extreme case.
So then you will take only unigram and
bigram.
Okay, Mahadev.
Yeah.
I mean,
question if there is such a situation.
Ma'am, in the sample you provided,
Trigam was 0.
Sec.
In sample, what?
In the sample example you provided,
trigram was 0.
Oh, a cha cha in this one. Okay,
that's why probably she asked me.
The blue score, yeah.
Yes, yes.
Here you are saying none of them have 3
words at a time. This, the which, yeah,
Yes.
okay, slap the, okay, fine.
That's why probably, yeah,
then you should focus on bigram. Yeah,
that's why I said that trigram is very
tricky because when you have the number
of words in English sentence,
which are like 5 words or 4 words,
Getting a trigram is going to be
challenging because there will be total
number of trigram itself will be one or
two.
And matching all of them would be a task.
Yeah, but ideally if you get it,
Yeah.
it's excellent.
If you have like many trigrams matching,
that means your whole translation is
almost matching to the reference.
So in this particular example,
you can stick to unigram and bigram.
If you're getting zero,
then you might have to do Laplace
smoothing and all those things.
So as I said,
there are advanced techniques,
advanced modified version of BLEU score.
In that,
probably they must be considering that
zero value also, how to avoid the zeros.
But here in our example,
you can ignore the trigram.
If you're getting zero,
just stick to uni and bigram.
Okay,
thank you everyone for the patience till
Okay, ma'am. Thank you.
OK, thanks, man.
the end of the day.
I really admire you all. Okay, bye bye.
See you next time.
Thank you, man.
Thanks.
Thank you, ma'am.
Thank you. Bye bye.
Umang.
SP.